-You almost could not be here.
-I almost didn´t make it
to the show tonight.
-Because of jury duty.
-Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-That´s so fantastic.
-You know,
I know that people say
that they only get called once
every four years,
but I´m telling you --
I get called all of the time.
They love me.
-I get it.
[ Light laughter ]
-They can´t get enough of me.
I literally --
in the last four months,
I have been asked to go
to petty court,
which I thought was petite...
[ Laughter ]
...grand jury
and federal jury --
or Supreme Court
and Federal Court.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And I -- you know,
when you get that thing
in the mail, everybody --
us New Yorkers are like,
"My life is more important
than doing my civic duty."
-Yeah, exactly.
-You know? I mean...
And I´m actually civic-minded.
I mean,
I actually pick up after my dog,
and, you know, I don´t --
I don´t jump
over the turnstiles.
And, you know, I vote.
But, like, there´s something
so irritating about it.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
And so,
you start to talk to people,
and they´re like, "Oh, my God,
well, if you get to voir dire,"
you know --
-Sure.
-That´s when they ask you
all these questions, like,
"What´s your favorite --
Like, what´s your hobbies?"
I mean,
they ask you odd questions.
But they -- they´re --
basically, you´re getting close
to picked --
being picked for a jury.
If you get there,
just start lying.
And just say --
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah, just start saying, like,
"I don´t believe in the criminal
justice system as it is today."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And, like, "I don´t think it´s
fair that people go to jail."
And so you literally
start convincing yourself,
"I´m gonna say that.
Like,
I´m actually gonna do that."
And then,
you walk in to the courtroom,
and it looks like
a real courtroom
because it´s a real courtroom.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And --
And then a judge comes out.
And he looks like a real judge.
-Yeah.
-Like, he´s not like
the "Law & Order" judge
that you thought.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-And suddenly, you´re like,
"I can´t lie! I can´t lie."
And they make you take the oath.
-Yeah.
-And -- And he talks about
solemnizing the proceedings,
which, I´ve never heard used
in that context.
And you´re like,
"I swear to take -- to tell
the whole truth
and nothing but the truth."
And -- And you´re literally
thinking, "I´m gonna lie."
And then -- And then you
start to get, like, weepy,
´cause you´re like, "Oh, my God,
the defendant is there.
And he really counts on me,
you know..."
-By the way --
-"...to show up."
-And you´re surprised
they keep bringing you back?
You´re a dream juror.
[ Laughter ]
You´re the dream --
everything about this!
They´re like,
"Well, that lady --
There was that one lady
who cried..."
[ Laughter ]
"...when the judge stood up
and made everybody take an oath.
We got to get her back here."
[ Laughter ]
I´m sure everybody else
was on their phone,
lying about everything,
saying, like,
"I think like, shoplifting
should be the death penalty."
They´re like, "Get out of here.
We´ve got Kyra Sedgwick.
We don´t need you, you lunatic."
[ Light laughter ]
-Yeah, too much empathy.
I´ve definitely -- Yeah.
-Too much empathy.
Well, I want to talk to you
about -- well, this is empathy,
but you care a lot
about thoughts and feelings.
-Yes.
-But are you coming
to a realization about this now,
or you must have always cared
about thoughts and feelings.
´Cause you strike me as someone
who´s always cared about --
-No, I´ve always cared
about thoughts and feelings.
-Yeah.
-I mean, like, it´s a --
I literally had -- When my --
you know, my kids were little,
I´d be like,
"Well, what are you feeling?
Well, what are you thinking?
Well, what are you feeling?
Well, what are you thinking?"
We literally had a game
called "Thoughts and Feelings,"
and they would hide it,
´cause they didn´t want to play
the Thoughts and Feelings game.
-Was it a --
Was it a board game?
-It was a board game.
-Oh, my God.
-It made you talk
about thoughts and feelings.
But, you know, I mean,
this is the great thing
about having girlfriends,
is that they never tire
of talking
about thoughts and feelings.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Never.
You know, I mean,
no detail is too small.
No emotion
is too minor to share,
you know, in deep, in depth,
in detail.
The other day, I was having
dinner with my friend.
We were at two hours.
And like, I´m asking her
everything about everything.
Like, "What did you have
for breakfast?
And what did you wear
the day you went in to see your
boss and ask for a raise?
Like, how did you feel
in the morning?"
[ Laughter ]
Like,
"Tell me every single thing."
And we went
to the bathroom together,
because women
go to the bathroom together.
-This is something that --
-I´ve noticed that, yeah.
-Yeah. This is something
that men don´t do.
But we went
into the bathroom together.
Plenty of stalls, but we had to
go into the stall together.
-Really?
-Didn´t want to miss a nuance,
you know?
Didn´t want to miss a --
you know, a --
-You -- I excuse you
from jury duty.
[ Laughter ]
So, you go into the stall
together, just to keep chatting?
-Yeah, to keep chatting.
You don´t want to miss anything.
And, like, talking over
the stall is not good enough.
I need to see the face.
I need to --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
Are you concerned that
other people in the bathroom
are aware...
-No.
-...that there are now
two people chatting away?
-No.
-Okay. That´s great.
-I don´t worry
about those things.
-Yeah, no --
-I told Kev that story.
He´s like, "You know, you can --
I can guaran-damn-tee it
that no guy goes into a urinal,
like, you know,
and has some guy right next
to him talking to him,
because they can´t be apart."
I mean, of course, they´re --
-I think that´s very safe.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-I will say,
´cause I recently saw you
and your husband, Kevin Bacon,
and you are the best-looking
couple in show business.
-Oh, my God, no.
-And if there was anyone --
[ Cheers and applause ]
If there was any guy
I would share a stall with,
it would be your husband.
-[ Laughs ]
-So...
[ Light laughter ]
-You´re not the only one.
-Yeah, no,
I´m sure there´s like --
-Many a time, he´s had his...
in his hand...
- Yeah.
-...and people have asked
for autographs...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...and pictures, selfies.
-Wow.
-Just really easy. Just...
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]